the White House is strongly defending
president Trump's declaration of a
national emergency on the us-mexico
border senior advisor Stephen Miller
indicates the president is ready to veto
any effort by Congress to overturn the
move the president said on Friday he
expected to be sued and he predicted he
will win Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
Nancy good morning good morning and
House Democrats are likely to file that
joint resolution of disapproval next
week and they'll likely have enough
Republican support to have it make its
way through Congress lawmakers who
believe that the president overstepped
his executive authority the president
can't defend this country then he cannot
fulfill his constitutional oath of
office White House senior adviser
Stephen Miller defended President
Trump's controversial move Sunday he
could choose to ignore this crisis
choose to ignore this emergency as
others have but that's not what he's
going to do but the president's own
words I didn't need to do this but I'd
rather do it much faster may have opened
him up to legal challenges including one
being filed by California's Attorney
General and at least six other states
declaring a national emergency enables
the President to take funds from the
Defense Department and other agencies to
build a border wall
it's a dangerous precedent we should not
set the terrible precedent of letting a
president declare a national emergency
simply as a way of getting around the
congressional appropriation process a
resolution of disapproval is likely to
pass the House and Senate but it would
take a two-thirds vote in both chambers
to override a presidential veto
Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
supports the president I don't think
there's any chance that the veto will be
overridden I think there are plenty of
votes in the house to make sure that
there's no override of the President's
veto so it's going to be settled in
court we'll have to wait and see and
because of that presidential veto this
joint resolution is likely to be more of
a symbolic measure as for the legal
fight outside groups like the ACLU say
they're going to be filing suit as well
and the president Gale has
he's willing to go all the way to the
Supreme Court and nobody doubts that he
will do that we're all watching Thank
You Nancy